foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us today my name
is Andrew Olson I'm with kaijin digital
insights and I'll be your host moderator
for today's webinar titled single cell
analysis of the tumor microenvironment
in high grade serous ovarian cancer
today's speaker is John Wall below he is
a PhD senior scientist at kaijin digital
insights and before joining kaijin
digital insights Dr below joint
Ingenuity systems in 2008 as a staff
scientist for in silica research
programs in oncology and infectious
diseases he holds a PhD in blood cell
biology from Paris 7 and completed his
postdoctoral work at the Scripps
Research Institute in San Diego
California where he studied the impact
of the feline immunodeficiency virus and
born and disease virus on brain cells he
pursued his career at the vaccine
Research Institute of San Diego where he
co-developed a universal vaccine
platform using the core antigen of the
Hepatitis B virus to Target infectious
viral and parasitic diseases and
metabolic diseases and cancer with that
I'd like to welcome Dr Bill
thank you Andrew thank you very much
today I'm going to present you a very
important use cases and dear to my heart
um and it's about the single analysis of
the tumor microorgan motor very serious
and lethal disease which is high grade
service of iron carcinoma
so before going any further I would just
like to give you a little summary of
what we are talking about that ovarian
carcinoma is a very serious disease as I
said
and we're talking about 300 000 women
being dinos worldwide each year and
unfortunately 200 000 women are going to
die from that disease the high grade
Services
accounting for 70 percent of the death
in these ovarian cancer
it's a very hard to diagnose has a very
high level of recurrence and as of now
we don't have any perfect treatment at
all so one idea is to study what we talk
about
um the the environment that allows and
the tumor operation and this is about
the tumor micro environment what is it
it's all the cells including cancer
cells on the Terrell cells epithel cells
immune cells that allow the cancer cells
to progress to metastatize and and be
and very efficient at what they are
doing and the role of the tumor micro
environment is to balance that so either
promoting or fighting and it's all about
the correct balances
so a little bit of a legal disclaimer
that all the products I'm going to show
out just for molecular biology
application only
and we are going to ask basically three
questions
we are going to analyze the molecular
role of cellular subset in that cancer
using single cell sequencing and mainly
we can look at the cell type which one
are involved what kind of marker we can
help to distinguish this cell type what
is the biology which is under our
opinion that the molecular Pathways the
transcriptional program and also we can
compare what we are going to find in
that single cell analysis to a bunch of
other comparison that we have in our
database and we are lucky to have that
so I'm going to present you three little
teasers and as you will notice there is
a DOT on the side and my point is to
tell you how we can use our technology
to cover basically all aspects of the
biology that we would like to
so here it's called analyzers I just
represent some graphical summary which
is a basically a synopsis of what's
going on in your data set and just to
give you a couple of example I will
detail that a little bit more so we can
analyze we can also compare because we
are lucky enough to have over 100
000 comparison expression that came from
omic self which is a product that I'm
going to talk about as well we are
allowed to look at any type of
comparison we would like what type of
Pathways what type of activity for a
particular apps from regulator and so on
so that is the compare tool but also we
can contextualize so once I have found
something interesting what do we know
about it and we're going to use
um the web versions of a mix of called
land Explorer which is attached to IPA
from the gene view link and here we can
simply look at one particular agent in
one context and find out a lot of it so
that's the idea now let's go back to
my agenda today
I'm going to describe a little bit what
is our ecosystem the sample to Insight
developed by Kaizen digital insight
we are going to process the data using a
dynamic workbench we're going to analyze
as I said we're going to compare as much
as we can
evaluate in relation about the data and
we are going to contextualize as much as
we can as well and bring you some
conclusions
so the ecosystem that we have developed
by calcium is is basically from the
sample collection to the interpretations
we have a set of technology that are
really well adapted
and on the far right here we have the
data analysis column and the
interpretation column
two products I'm going to talk about
today the CLC genomic workbench which
allows me to process any type of fastq
file on my query or even matrixes as
I've done here for the single cells and
the interpretation will be using Kaizen
Ingenuity pathway analysis which is the
flagship for biological and protection
worldwide Thai with land Explorer which
is the tool that I'm going to allows me
to contextualize the data I have found
right and I'm going to touch base a
little bit of a new database that we
have released recently
so what is the case we are it's based on
a clinical concern research paper
publishing two uh so um 2022 and they
wanted to look at using single cell RNA
sequencing the tissue architecture of
that High Grade Civil server in
carcinoma
so they have gathered a tumor sample
from patients that have done specific
surgery
they have also known magnavion samples
and that have
undermine that I have a
underwent also some type of surgery but
we are going to use the normal parts of
that non-magnant ovary you so we have
tumor and normal tissues they use 10x
genomics it's a good use because the CLC
genomic workbench can process that
especially the V3 chemistry we are going
to align to b38 and quantify as normal
and we're going to give some dimensional
reduction using umap here I'm going to
show you one cases
so here it's a cartoon to simplify
exactly as a buyer desire I will use it
right you have single cell first queue
file here it was matrixy so think it's a
matrix I have a metadata which is
attached you import that into the
premium module of genomic world bench
you process it according to specific
workflow that has been already
set it's very easy stepwise process and
you can directly send us the beauty send
the data directly to IPA an IPA which
include analysis match I'm going to
describe that in the next tutorial now
you can compare you can contact
contextualize and you can explore the
biology of that specific data set
here this is the workflow from General
bench so here's a tag process I'm going
to process the Matrix The Matrix has
been used from several Ranger from 10
net genomics it's a Mex format and
basically it's a it's a it's a workflow
already set a new process you add the
classifier of Enterprise because you are
multiple sample you can iterate and
collect through and you head up to a
very important information at the end
heat map
expressionplot.blob Matrix anywhere and
so on all of
foreign
this is the Matrix I have imported as I
said they are from The Mex format cell
Roger from 10x genomics and the protocol
is basically once you have set up your
Consortium genome your Gene model which
is The Ensemble v99 you know what type
of classifier we use which is the
version 1.2 as of now
we are going to process all these
different matrices we have five of them
that are normal tissues and seven of
them that are different
grade of the hybrid cells over
incarcinoma to grade one two grade two
and two grade three stage three here
this is the meta and the metadata which
is attached process directly from the
Matrix information as you can tell you
have normal tissues and concept issues
so I can separate everything I want even
based on age or based on the type of
pathology right
so what do we get is a u map and the
umap is basically here a 2d I could show
you a 3D but it's a 2d representation of
what are the cell type that are
represented in that cancer and normal of
iron tissues so here I simplify for the
sake of the presentation we have roughly
10 main cell type and there is more the
paper I described a little bit more
because they went a little deeper I
don't think it was the point here but we
are basically macrophages Tina for site
natural Killers a bunch of plab plasma
cells fibroblasts all over the place
here on the table cells some mayo
fibroblasts some benefits right and a
huge chunk of eptails alike this is the
whole presentation as is everything
confused normal and concept issues but
now I can color as well that
umap based on the staging and the normal
tissues this is the color code yellow
stage one as you can tell epithelial
some T cells and so on and you have the
purple and you're right going for stage
two and stage three right so now we can
easily look at different expression
profile based on some criteria that we
can decide
one of the good um the features that we
have in uh CRC GMA workbench is the
violent plot so basically indicating for
a particular tissue a particular cell
type here this is the plasma cells we
know they are B cells that produce
antibodies what are the most
representative genes in that particular
cells well as you can tell it's all
about immunoglobulinoplated heavy chain
light chain and so on so this is a very
nice conformations that what I find out
and using the classifier as a plasma
cell it's actually a plasma cells
but we can also look at a heat map based
on the cell type and the disease status
in other words
what are the most based on 20 genes here
what are the uh the cell type in which
these genes are the most represented so
it's based on the expression influence
here the more red more expressed right
but what I would like to show you here
is these uh three uh Legend here we have
one for the disease one for the cell
type and there's a color code here on
the right and one for the stage is a
little bit more confused one striking
thing is for the yellow which is the
concierge type regardless of the stage
is the most prevalent cells are actually
the epithelials right now you look at
the normal tissue which is in blue here
which correspond to that Legend the most
prevalent cells are the fibroblasts and
that's a normal uh features of
um
the ovion tissues of women that are
aging and the a little bit more
fibroblast is in place right and
everything else after you you have all
the other set types that are described
in that Legend here on that color code
so that was the one striking element
that I've seen and that confirms based
on the paper as well and regular data
overlying tissues in aging woman
okay we can also Define
um a specific marker and the way we do a
specific marker is basically taking one
type of cells versus the rest of the
cells and compel it what I wanted to
show you is the marker for macrophages
versus device when you are stage three
which is the advanced stage delayed
stage of that concern right in between
metastasis and heavy metastasis and what
you look at that population which I
Define as macrophage monocytes again we
can probably go deeper it's probably a
M2 type of microphages but I'm not going
there and the marker that we have
defined is the top one is msf1 that is a
top macrophage marker at stage three in
that particular High Grade Civil server
and casino map so when I talk about
contextualizations I wanted to know a
little bit more about that marker where
is it on which so we have lucky to get a
lot of land so collection of that asset
one of them is the blueprint and the
blueprint is a collection of data set
that Encompass malignant and not
Management in metopatic cells so here I
selected in which type of cells
basically the msr1 marker is expressed
and as you can tell it's kind of a
confirmation and it's relieve the M2 and
M1 macrophages basically macrophages are
the one that Express the most that msr1
marker so again when you have the
process the data you have the expression
profile you know where it's located you
can get information based on other data
sets such as blueprint here which come
from then Explorer
now let's look at the differential
expression analysis of that particular
single cell and you can set up any sort
of comparison the one I look at is based
on stage
right and looking at all group pairs
basically this kind of comparison a PTL
cells I want to look at the stage three
versus normal I could have done for
fibroblaster or lymphocytes the same
things
the beauty of it is in our ecosystem
everything is style so once you have CLC
you have a plugin that allows to send
the informations to apa and I can do
that by itself not only upload the data
set and set up the parameter of the
analysis that's what I've done here it's
just an automatic process I set up some
color for the p-value for change and you
see some of the comparison I've sent
and it's directly sent to API and in IPA
we can use many mini feature and what I
would like to propose today not not
unfortunately a key for the treatment of
I grad service over in carcinoma but
more an approach to understand what type
of Technology we can gather to get
reasonable hypothesis right
so here this is the graphical summary
I'm very proud of that features because
the graphical summary is basically a
synapses of
um drawn by Machine learning algorithm
that will connect the most important
biological entities that you have in
your data set right based on genes as
you can tell here based on disease based
on Pathways and you connect all of them
and everything is done automatically and
that's what does it do it provides you a
very clear image what's going on in that
data set so I give you two examples
natural killers and fibroblasts natural
killer stage 3 versus normal same for
fibroblast what you can reasonably see
is just looking at that graphical
summary again this is done automatically
I don't have any input in that it P put
the pieces together you can see that
the cellular function of natural
formulas match well together to promote
that environment of hybrid series of
iron carcinoma very important Genie GF
cd40 some interferable pathways are
involved but also fibroblast fibrosis
which is induced and so on so these are
very nice sediment and nice features you
have in IPA that in a matter of sudden
looking at the balances okay I know
what's going on now
but let's compare because I'm lucky
enough to have all these comparison I
provide eight comparison here from the
left to the right I have natural kilo
microphages epithelial plasma
tenorphosites under Italian fibroblast
and myophoblast all stage three versus
normal and I just quickly use the
comparison analysis feature in ipn and
compare all of them and what you see is
a bunch of color right blue and orange
it's very simple orange is the
prediction of activation and blue is a
collection of inhibitions So based on
the genes that are overlapping that
particular Pathways of anteras that you
see in that list on the left here we can
predicate that pathway is done no no
turn off so I wanted to summarize
because it could be a little bit uh
overwhelming here but I want to say uh
summarize I am sorry summarize by bullet
point here what what's going on in that
particular uh tumor micro environment
you have first of all a general
um inhibition of the protein synthesis
um it's special protein synthesis but
all the set types as you can see here
they are predicted to be inhibited you
may have also activated epigenetic and
transcriptional repression specifically
in Tina phosite as you can see here this
is highly
um activated for that particular cells
here and also you have an activated
fibrosis you see that in other Italian
and fibroblast you have different
regulation of the actines like
cytoskeleton
particular inhibition in aptl cells
Activision in Tina phosite and
fibroblast
a decrease in introduction of cell
deaths you've seen that in natural
killer antenna forcites you have a
general inhibition of the cell cell
adhesions especially in epithelial cells
all of that contribute to what we call
epithelial to muscle camera transitions
that polarize the metastatic right you
create a niche and you you colonize that
that's the way cancer cells do and you
need all of this phenomenon to happen to
promote that
concern you have a general inflammation
it's very increasing tenorphosites
fibroblast again this is one of the
Hallmark of cancer
you have an increase in positiveness
you've seen that a lot in fibroblasts
and my fibroblast and finally you see an
increased cell survival inodotelia
fibroblasts and myofibromobascals so
just looking at that comparison you have
a general overview of what's up in that
cancer situations where pretty much all
the cells immune and non-immunes stroma
cells cancer cells are all fighting to
each other either to promote the
environment for the console to thrive or
to fight the concept progressions
now let's go a deeper a little bit and
we can look at
features that we have a collapse in
literature and basically a feature that
allows us to look at the transcriptional
program what is going on who is driving
who is the conductor in that in that
tumor micro environment and here I have
selected because I can select many type
of molecule could be transcription
regulator as you as I as you can see
here could be cytokine could be kinase
but I selected the transcription
regulator basically transcription Factor
as we know it and I selected those that
were predicted to be activated so those
that are leading a program that will
allow specific phenomena right and I
noticed uh four of them are pretty
important very very high score KDM 5A
back one nanog and crime so first of all
I wanted to look at the representation
in that Human by probability to you
before where are they expressed so you
just have to believe me all these four
transcription factor I expressed
ubiquitously in all normal cells that's
that's the normal effect but they are
expressed also as you can tell he nanerg
in the aptl cells this is this cluster
all of that are iptl cells back one Prem
nkd m5a are all expressed in cancer
cells in epithel cells and now what I
can do using that is I can click it's
very simple system you click all of that
and you display one network that
encompasses all these four transcription
factors they are there all of them and I
know back one kram and KDM 5A they are
all predicted to be activated the color
is orange and what we have done here we
have uh put the network in with the
molecule that are associated dot stream
of each of these particular
transcription Factor they are associated
by S expression and transcription edges
and based on the expression of these
genes you see here green is done related
in the stage three versus normal or red
will be application's previous system
Alpha epithelial cells here based on
that expression pattern we have
determined that all of these
transcription Factor politics to be
activated very nice Disco
for for the beauty of of the
presentation here I also asked the
question when when I have a program like
that of transcription Factor what type
of process I can see and as you can see
statistically significant you have a
tumor progression of your PTL cells in
particular so just these four guys here
are permitting a big push of tumor
progressions 99 of these differential
expressions are driven by these four
guys so must be really important
I would like to contextualize now
because let's say I don't know anything
about this transcription factor I would
like to know a little bit more in
relation to that concept well
first of all we can look at survival
right so based on the expression of
nanog what is the relation with survival
in ovarian carcinoma
and as you can see the increased
expression of analog decreased survival
in ovarian Casino all of these data are
tied to I grid service organ Cinema so
nanog becomes a marker if you have a
high expression of Nano you have a
decreased survival
that a marker is involving on
premierextem self-proliferation when you
want and pluripotency so no no surprise
that it's associated with the poor
pognization resistance to chemotherapy
so that's one information that if you
didn't know you find that very easy
let's look at back one and KDM 5 and I
wanted to see why uh how these guys are
correlated to each other right and in in
what type of cell they are expressed so
you can look at the expression of these
two guy back one and Kenny m5a in
specific immune cells obviously I choose
again the blueprint which is a
hematopoietic stem cells by England or
not I selected the normal situations
here and here it's a color code of all
the cells but let me tell you you have
mainly monocytes and mainly lymphocytes
and this is based on the log 2 transform
of expression back one or cadm5
basically these guys are highly
expressed in both type of cells what's
important is the back one is involved in
a regression of oxidative Thrice which
is a very key factors in progression of
tumor cell cycle hematopoiesis and
Immunity and recently the transcription
regulator of iron carcinoma has been
shown to promote EMT for the back one
let's look at KDM 5A which is a lysine
specific dimetilaise well it inhibits
the anti-tumor response Innova and
carcinoma it's a recent paper in 22.
and it can promote also EMT and it's
correlated to chemo resistance as we
know when you use these cell lines but I
wanted to know using a new database that
we have called tumor mutation based on
the b37
consensus genomes what is the percentage
of alter samples when you look at KDM 5
well and you have a color code
amplification mutations well the KDM 5
Innovation carcinoma is a heavily
um
mutated in these and amplify in this
type of cancer so here we have three
different correlations we know they are
tied together we know the decrease of
survival and we know when they amplify
their title weing carcinoma that's the
contextualizations part
now let's try to play a little bit with
the compare idea what's up with our data
versus the rest stop and we had over the
years
um look at combining very important
piece of informations one of them is
comparison expression data set we have
rough roughly right now 118 000
differential expression that I said that
come from a mix of dynamics of has over
the years curating normalized data sets
that have been public source
tcga links and you name it and they have
processed in such a way an elegant way
that we have a vocal control vocabulary
attached with so we can do a lot of
information this data set has been
pushed and into IPA
and now we're in the
features called analysis match which I
will present later we are going to see
what's up with the rest of the world
when I want to query my own
data set expression that I set and see
what's going on in the rest of the world
this data set Encompass many things
oncological non-ecological single cell
and even normal tissues so you see the
power we have here
and not just another representations but
that is important to say not only we
combine these expression that I said
that has been curating normalize control
vocabulary but we bring also our
knowledge base which bring more than 10
million curated findings by phe experts
that organized structural database so
the power of two togethers now it's huge
so I'm going to show you three different
things
um that has been developed in the last
three four years Activity plot but then
search analysis match
we are going to look at the patent
Searchers what is it
the pattern search is let's say you have
a network and here this is one of the
case you have some that are predicted
some that are are pre-related some are
done related but this is basically a
network
you can look and query
where do I see that in the rest of the
world the world being the our universe
which is this 118
000 comparison expression data set I
would like to know where do I find any
match or anti-match of that particular
patent search I would like to find that
okay and I'm going to give you an
example
first of all we we know that the
fibroblasts are prevalent in that
tumor micro environment we know they
promote invasions we know they promote
metastasis on geogenesis basically
everything necessary for the cancer
cells to pump to
Focus I have selected using the upstrom
regulator two very important
transcription factors that are known to
be a master regulator or VMT twist one
here
I have added another one is PDF so twist
one and Z1 are predicted to be activated
activated and sbdf which is very
important component for cell migration
is predicted to be inhibited what I've
done on the left part is I put that
Network and I ask the question what are
the main functions as you can see the
main functions are metastasis predicted
to be increased in version of two more
ability to increase and generally is
predicted to be increased and over and
concept as well here as you can say so I
know for that particular conversion of
fibroblast stage three versus normal I
know twist one and Z1 are extremely
important along with spdf well I didn't
know too much about sbdf and I would
like to know
where is the express as well as twist
one and Zeb one so I'm going back to the
U map and using a color code as well you
can tell sbdf is many explains in the
epitl sellers the dark blue right
Z1 and twist one are all expressed in
fibroblast and other immune cells
basically that one is a little bit more
ubiquitous twist one is more in a
fibroblast part here and spdf is
uniquely in the PTL cells so it's very
interesting because from one comparison
you do not necessarily have the
transcription factor which is pertinent
to that particular cells it could be
from another type of cells that's the
case here well I wanted to know when
twist one is over X price again I'm
using another database that which is
from a mix of under a web based version
land explorer that you can access from
geneview in IPA it's complicated but we
can explain that a little bit more in
detail I'm looking at twist one
expression in metastatic tissue in high
grade serious over and castle by using
the Encore human b38 gingo 33 as you can
tell here this is based on the log 2
transform expression of twist one and I
look at different samples right primary
tumor solid two more regular terminal as
you can tell twist one is overly
expressed in metastatic which is a
confirmations of what we know because
twitch one is mainly a promoter of the
MTN metastasis so here binary dependent
sources we can find that twist one is
effectively in high grade service around
carcinoma over Express in metastatic
tissue
but let's go back to that idea of
pattern
I wanted to know when I have so let's go
back to that particular Network twist
one zeb1 spdf1 network I'm going to find
out where is it where do you find that
that's the patent search I have a
particular pattern up and down genes uh
apps to be activated one predicted to be
inhibited and I would like to know in
what other situation that particular
network is represented so here I'm lucky
enough I have over 100
000 analysis that contain these three
guys and I'm looking for high Z score in
other words I'm looking for comparison
that match and resemble very much what I
found in the fibroblast stage 3 versus
normal and I didn't do anything yet I
didn't filter so when you click on these
guys you have that window that happened
here and it mainly shows this is in
single cells without any filtering
and you look at the type of comparison
it's always cell type versus others and
mainly fibroblasts but that's my
view here but I can look and ask a
question about the stats and looking at
evaluation of the metadata per se so
having a
unbiased way well that's what I've done
here this is a click on Evolution
metadata and you can see what is the
most important
of these 200 analysis that I've selected
here what is the most representation
well you can tell it's all about
fibroblast it's all about stromal cells
fibroblasts is a stromal sense it's
always in in cancer situations so the
network I found
in my fibroblast state-free versus
normal is actually resembling a
fibroblast signature in other Concepts
so it's a very important fact because
now I know I am on to something I can
focus on that particular cell type and
focus on that particular transcription
factor to see what we can tweak a little
bit right so again that spdf twist one
Z1 Network representative fiber
signature in conservative could do that
because I have pattern search if not I
would not have been able to look at that
let's look at another another aspect
call the Activity plot a TBT plot it's
basically you know I've talked about
canonical Pathways and talk about
arsenalature what I would like to know
here in What occasion and what condition
what this is what treatment that
particular let's say is activated or
inhibited while we use a feature call
Activity plot and that's what I'm going
to do here
I I selected another type of cells the
endotrial cells which are prevalent in
the tumor micro environment which are
basically here
that cluster and I ask what are the
transcription factors that are predicted
to be activated I selected specifically
gross factor I have a specific interest
here
and as you can tell two of them strike
my attention fgf2 and agf they're all
activated in order trial cells when you
compare cells reverse system agf2
energyf very strong Cisco
and you dig a little bit in the
information you can use the gene view
you have a lot of details and permade ID
and papers you can go through to query a
lot of information that's what I've done
basically staying into the IPA ecosystem
what you look is fgf2 is a very
important androgenic factor it has
actually induced EMTs along with others
right in overhand cancer
it's known that you dysregulate its
expression it's always associated with
aggressive cancer phenotype and enhance
chemotherapy resistance again one of the
main issues that we have in high grade
series of and carcinoma is chemo
resistance and not only you dinos very
late but
it's hard to the the drug doesn't work
very well they work for a time in and
they disappear right and that
dysregulation is associated with
proclinical outcomes on the other part
agf is known to promote Invasion and
migration of ovarian cancer cells it's
upregulation on the signalergy of cement
is associated with
prognosis as well right
I can dig a little bit further I know
fgf2 when I look at my IP and I build
the connection between energy J2 and hgf
which is not necessarily prevalent here
not obvious we know that fgf to increase
expression in GF and that I can do that
because I have the knowledge base under
my disposal when I use IPM
let's look at the expression of these
two guys lgf2
is expressed in the autotelia heavily in
the fibroblast right and I give you the
proportion of these Expressions it's
mainly
um lower expression in uh high grade
very high in uh normal tissues but still
and agf is mainly expressed in
fibroblast again blue and microphages
here as you can tell that's the light
blue here and the proportion is
equivalent in cancer or normal tissue
so remember we talk about the activity
product let's keep that in mind so first
of all I put a network a GF is predicted
to be activated lgf2 as well this is the
genes that are a downstream of these two
transcription course factor and what's
striking as well again is when you grow
statistically significant functions
using the goal features you see all
these different type of important
formation increase of cell movement or
epithelial cells
remember the comparison that I've seen
here at the beginning was undertale
cells and you can get information for
other type of cells including cellular
infiltration by local sites you promote
EMT you promote metastasis generally
YouPorn migration tumor cells and you
decrease hypothesis very important
information you have with these two
transcription Factor well
uh what I would like to know because
let's say I didn't know too much about
the GF and I wanted to know what
simulation with the GF and tp53 why tp53
because this is the most mutated Genie
Novi and carcinoma 91 of the case
according to tcga we have a mutation of
tp3 so that tumor suppressor is mutated
and here you can see the expression of
the agf based on the status of mutation
of tp53 not statues but expression of
tp53
its agf is highly expressed when tpc3 is
down right and it's obviously correctly
when it's lower expression when it's up
so everything works well so in a
situation where you have high mutation
very low expression of tpp3 Innova in
casino igf is up so again it makes sense
to see at that Network when you look at
the GF any gf2 right
I can ask a couple of other questions
before I show you the Activity plot is
um
the mutation data of hgf right again I
didn't know anything and we have that
tool and Explorer which is tied to IPA
well I can look based on the stage to
clinical stage stage 4 2C and 3C what is
the type of mutation you have for igf
Innovation amount you can t as you can
tell here a lot of application when
you're in stage three everything I've
shown you so far it stays free versus
normal so we you we have some kind of
collection ship which is agf
amplification and over in Casino I can
even loot using a gene view genome view
the type of DNA seek mutations of these
agf according to the different stages
and you have a color code for the type
of mutation so it's very useful finally
I would just like to touch base with
something that is really important in
our ecosystem which is hsmd looking at
basically think Al data of agf a
cross-cancer for that particular genes
well hsmd human somatic mutation
database is new right it's a newly
developed by occasion and has content
from a knowledge page which is expertly
curated content and also data from Real
World oncology in cases from a
professional clinical impression
services and what it does is quickly I
query agf and you can have on the bottom
it's a small screenshot here but the
type of alteration you find for ngf a
cross-cancer right what type of
functional impact you have on the
particular protein the actionability
which is you know the clinical
significance one tier two according to
amp ASCO and so on you have that quickly
and on that one you have a tier 2 which
is a potential clinical significance for
when you have an amplification when I
click on that and you you can look at
the type of a clinical product what's
going on for that particular
amplification of a GF when you see the
drugs the specificity of the profile of
a GF when it's positive when it's over
Express amplify and different clinical
studies you have for the different
concealer it's very easy very very
simple tool to use
but let's go back to Activity plot I'm
asking the question when does agf is
increase
so I specifically ask a question when is
it when is it increased in cancer so I
selected the database colon kojo again
come from Land Explorer which is the web
version of a mix of and that's the only
filter this is all these Bunch which are
on green that are very high this score
so showing that agf as an absolometer is
predicted to be activated and this is
the bunch of data set we have SIMPLE I'm
going to look at the metadata when does
agf activity is up well guess what agf
when you look at disease State and
treatment and tissue you realize that
agf is at is active is
increase in presence of hgf2 as you can
tell here in very high percentage so you
have a strong Association
of agf activity and gf2 activity so
therefore the network I've seen before
which I didn't know anything about I can
find that this is a known phenomenon
across concept or at least highly
prevalent see that's the beauty of
having Activity plot so and finally
let's look at analysis match and what is
it I know this match you know we have
all these data set I talk about 118 000
and for each of them uh coming from a
mix of we have calculated the Cisco for
the canonical Pathways for the Epson
regulator for other things I didn't talk
about such as disease and functions and
so on and we have a general disco and
basically what we are providing for odds
each of these 118 000 data set value of
this score for the canonical Pathways
from letter and so on right and like
that you can see if what your own data
sets you're going to query against have
any similarity with any other data set
in what context
let me give you an example but first of
all I would like to show you a very nice
representation we have right now for the
clinical pathway it's a bubble chart
and I just wanted wanted to show you a
customizations I have the pathway
category that we have in uh IPA we have
over 750 canonical pathway already
preset with different category as you
can tell gross Factor categories cell
cycle nuclear receptor and so on and I
put on the except this is the Z score so
basically what you see here is orange
and blue first of all on the left it's
blue so a every pathway that are
predicted to be inhibited only around
every pathway the ability to be
activated but most importantly the size
also correspond to the number of all up
in genes that are in that particular
Pathways that allows the calculation of
the z-score but what I wanted to show
here this is about Tina fossil this is
an the comparison where I'm looking at
Tina fossat stage 3 versus normal
and you can tell there's a lot of things
going on in the cytokine cellular immune
responses cellular stress heavily
heavily orange and other things so the
bubble chart will give you a very quick
glance also of what's going on in your
data set obviously you can click on any
of this bubble and find out what is the
pathway UFO report if you don't know
what that pathway is talking about what
are the Gene and so on but let's go to
the match so I'm looking at my question
is when I have that Tina foresight stage
free versus normal in high grade service
I would like to know if there are any
similarities or the similarities to that
particular conversion in other concept
that's what I've selected so I selected
the on colon which include all
comparison expression in oncology colon
colon and I look at treatment versus
control I have a reason behind because I
would like to know in what conditions uh
that uh stage three versus normal
fortina for sites does it bring anything
of value for me is there any particular
treatment it is represent or is there
against or a decimal of treatment that
could be useful further after right so I
selected that there's 200 uh
the analysis being selected and what you
can tell when you look at the metadata
again are you that evaluation of the
metadata it's very clear the majority of
the treatment include interferon right
whether it's Gamma or Alpha so when you
select these conditions I want to look
at Tila for stage three versus normal in
all cancer and I look at just treatment
versus comparison it's all about
interfere all about that telephone and
very eyes Z score as you can tell for
their formulator well let's find out
so now I put
these different comparison that I have
selected here the one you have seen here
the 10 12 you've seen here I select that
and I project the heat map that's the
heat map you see on the left right
and that is tilaphosites at stage three
versus novel in comparison to many other
data sets and you as you can tell as
quick things when you sell a Capstone
regulator as the entity here there's a
clear program of activation and a clear
program of inhibition for some of the uh
absolutely and others right and the game
right now is to understand what's going
on here what's going on well we have the
metadata as I've said that comes from a
mix of because they have carefully
controlled the vocabulary and therefore
we can see what's going on in each of
these different header here which
correspond to one particular data set so
I click on each of them and I found out
a lot of information and the information
I want to resume is that one right two
aspect
first of all the metadata seems overall
indicates that targeting other genes
many make the addition of interfere for
raising and I'll teach you more response
and I'm going to put that very lightly
because anti-tumor response I can deform
that aspect I can also Define the
polymer response again I'm talking about
a balance here the fight to get rid or
promote the cancer is is really tricky
and all the cells combined do that but
that's what I found here for the metadat
first of all fgf2 receptor which is the
receptor of gf2 activating mutations has
been seen in breast cancer
and they are in combination of another
estrogen drugs and a map map kindness
one inhibitor it does suppress the
chemical resistance
to a food restaurant so very important
so that activation of that particular
guy is important
when we
inhibit one of the component of the
polycom represent complex prc2 the one
of the quality ZD when you inhibit that
component you induce regression of
tumors and graph in Vivo and we have
seen that in no logic in alphabet we
find out also that when we have a copper
collecting drugs that promote the pdl1
degradation remember pdl1 is used by the
concepts cells to promote their their
life right their cell their their cycle
when you promote that degradation you
increase the number of cd8 infecting
cells which are very important and
natural kilos by doing that you slow the
tumor growth and it has been seen you
improve the mass survival of
neuroblastoma
we find out also that when you have gsk3
Inhibitors you allow the wind
activations that reduce the formation
and improve the survival in another type
of cancer
we find out as well that we have make
individuals that counteract the
interfere resistance which is observing
CLL in clinic
and finally when you decorate and it's
very important I show that to you here
when you degrade that particular
compound curly cows which is by acting
on ethyl liquid in ligase you induce T
Cell activations and you induce
hypothesis and gross inhibition in
Magnum B cells and other diffuse large
b-cellular format right so just by
looking at that you have that type of
informations
for the scientific
Prospect I wanted also to show you in
red and in blue what you also found
looking other type of data you may have
in IPA you can see the interferon
Pathways as I say seems to promote and
autismo responses but it can go both
ways right it depends on the concept it
depends on the situation but gamma can
be a non-teachimo or a proteumor again
dependent conditions the anti-femeral
type one here as you can see and iraf1
are very anti-tumo Engineers but you see
in the same heat map Fox C1 and
prolactin and a prdms which is at the
same time activated or inhibited are
promoting the pro tumor environment it's
a very complex system but what I wanted
to show you you here is with ipn and
Explorer you you can have an overview of
everything that can be very useful to
understand and bring new hypothesis in
context and I would like to conclude
right
um first of all we can identify
biological clusters very important
we can see this is an entire play with
many cells of immune and non-immune
origin we can look at chemical Pathways
we can look at absolutely letters we can
see what are the different programs that
are in play and we can look at specific
cell specific signatures and try to look
uh from the rest of our universe which
is this huge set of data sets which is
you know basically 100 of years of work
at all these puzzles we can compare and
try to understand what's going on in our
data set on that note I would like to
thank you very much and I hope you have
appreciated that little presentation
thank you
thank you doctor though uh for that
wonderful and interesting talk we do
have a few questions that
um we'd like to send your way and and
address those uh first question uh is
the the umap plots that you showed
throughout your presentation do those
come from IPA or do they come from
something else so umap is a
representation of what they call
dimensional reductions and has been
provided by CLC genomic wapage
as a matter of fact you process the
metrics of rescue file one of the output
is that you map directly so it's very
easy and you have that representation in
2D or 3DS so CLC in that particular
situations
great okay and then uh another question
can the general processes for comparing
and contextualizing
um be applied to normal bulk rna-seq
data or is that only for single cell
data absolutely for any type of data
this is an example of single cell
because it's particularly trivial
particularly complicated but I've we
have done that many times for bug uh
bulk Arena yeah absolutely micro
anything you can imagine even proteomics
great great you did eight uh pairwise
comparisons in IPA how many comparisons
can IPA handle at once what's the limit
so for the visualization I put up to 20
uh here just for my laptop real estate
20 comparison here
um then then you can play with with the
different other comparison to make some
kind of a bigger statement but here here
is Twin
okay great thank you so in the match you
can select basically 100 of them right
but for the for the visualization itself
it's 20.
got it thank you
um are all the visualizations heat Maps
networks Etc uh exportable from IPA yep
yep you can gpeg PNG and tfia
right
um
do all IPA licenses have access to
analysis match and pattern search and
land Explorer
I would like to refer to uh the global
produ manager on the cells but ipn now
came I think analysis match and Explorer
it's uh it's an addendum I think right
right okay
and then a slide specific question
um did the data that you presented on
slide 22
come from the data set you analyzed
I'll let you get back go back to the 22.
yeah this one yes did the data that you
presented here come from
the data set you analyzed or is this
generalized data from another source so
this is generalized data from another
source uh three so I explained that omic
soft has curated and normalized
thousands of samples
make comparison
expression data set and they are
gathered in structure that we call on
colon this Islam and many others these
oncogio blueprint and two more mutations
are some of the lens that we have in
that omic soft that has been accessible
in land Explorer which is the web
versions that we can get directly from
my PhD in view so this is external data
and that's the beauty of it because now
it's unrelated to my own comparison
expression and give real information in
concept situation in T-cell situations
or what is the tumor that we have in
that particular genes so very external
very useful
great thank you for that clarification
okay I think that brings us to the end
of our question and answer session again
I'd like to thank Dr below for his
wonderful presentation and making
himself available for our questions and
answers and that concludes her
presentation for today thank you thank
you thank you
foreign